This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Cars, house paint, fertilizer, look around you. Pretty much everything was delivered in a shipping container. There are 20 million shipping containers now in the world, carried by 6,000 container vessels, all moving literal tons of stuff back and forth over the ocean. And it all started in 1956 when a trucker by the name of Malcolm McLean had an amazingly good idea. What if there was a container that could come off a ship full of goods and attach to a truck or a train? No need to move the goods from one container to the next. Goodbye to all the time and labor spent loading and unloading.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗马·马尔斯。汽车、房屋油漆、化肥，看看你周围。几乎所有东西都是用航运集装箱运送的。现在世界上有2000万个集装箱，由6000艘集装箱船承运，它们在海洋上运送着成吨的货物。这一切始于1956年，当时一个名叫马尔科姆·麦克利恩的货车司机有了一个极其绝妙的主意。如果有一个集装箱，可以从装满货物的船上卸下来，然后直接装到卡车或火车上呢？不需要把货物从一个容器搬到另一个容器。告别所有用于装卸的时间和劳动力。
McLean believed the shipping container could revolutionize the way goods moved around the world. Malcolm McLean became a very, very wealthy man. By 1982, he was actually one of the 400 richest Americans. Because, of course, the shipping container did revolutionize the way goods move. That's reporter Nicola Twilly. New, deeper ports were built for new, deeper ships,
麦克利恩相信，航运集装箱将彻底改变货物在全球运输的方式。马尔科姆·麦克利恩成了一个非常非常富有的人。到1982年，他实际上成为了美国400名最富有人物之一。因为，当然，航运集装箱确实彻底改变了货物的运输方式。这是记者尼古拉·特威利。为了容纳更大、更深的船只，人们修建了更新、更深的港口，
carrying more products. A cargo vessel in the late 1960s needed a crew of 50. A container ship five times the size needed just 18 people. Meanwhile, on shore, roughly three quarters of the hundreds of thousands of dockworkers who were needed to move goods on and off ships ended up losing their jobs. It only took one guy to operate the crane that lifted these big boxes. McLean's idea had created an incredibly more efficient global shipping industry,
运载着更多产品。20世纪60年代末的一艘货船需要50名船员。而大五倍的集装箱船只需要18个人。与此同时，在岸上，成千上万名原本需要将货物搬运上船和卸货的码头工人中，大约有四分之三最终失去了工作。操作起重机吊起这些大箱子只需要一个人。麦克利恩的想法创造了一个效率高得惊人的全球航运业，
but there was still one major problem. Actually, there were a lot of problems, but none as grapes, cheese. The shipping container worked well for dry cargo, like paper and cans and plastics, but perishable products were transported the same way they had been for decades, as bulk cargo in the hold of specially designed
但仍然有一个主要问题。实际上，有很多问题，但没有哪个比葡萄和奶酪更重要。航运集装箱非常适合干货，如纸张、罐头和塑料，但易腐烂的产品的运输方式与几十年来一样，作为散货放在专门设计的冷藏船的货舱里。
refrigerated ships. And in these refrigerated boats, the one giant cargo space could only be kept at one temperature. And the thing is that different products need different temperatures. Bananas need to be at a higher temperature than apples, and apples need to be kept warmer than, say, frozen meat. So most ships were limited to carrying one thing at a time. United Fruit's fleet of banana boats was perhaps the most famous example of these one item ships. The result of sending massive amounts of produce in one ship like this was that when a ship arrived
在这些冷藏船中，巨大的货舱只能保持一个温度。问题在于，不同的产品需要不同的温度。香蕉需要的温度比苹果高，而苹果的温度需要比冷冻肉类等保持得更高。因此，大多数船只一次只能运载一种货物。联合果品公司的香蕉船队可能是这些单一货物船只中最著名的例子。用一艘船运送大量农产品的结果是，当船到达
in port, it flooded the area with thousands of pounds of a single commodity. So it was like bananas for days and days and days, and then the next week bushels and bushels of apples everywhere. The market was flooded, food was wasted. Plus, while these refrigerated ships were delivering all the produce, the shipping container industry was missing out on a lot of business. However, by the 1970s, the container industry had started to build refrigerated containers, which it is my great pleasure to tell you
港口时，它会向该地区倾倒数千磅单一商品。所以就像连续好几天都是香蕉，然后接下来的一周到处都是一筐又一筐的苹果。市场饱和了，食物被浪费了。此外，当这些冷藏船运送所有农产品时，集装箱航运业错失了大量业务。然而，到了20世纪70年代，集装箱行业开始建造冷藏集装箱，我很高兴地告诉大家，
are referred to within the industry as reefers. Dude. I know. And with an entirely straight face. But the reefers they had designed weren't working very well. Food would show up at the destination Rotten or Moldy and no one understood why. The container industry had a refer problem and they needed help.
它们在行业内被称为冷藏箱（reefers）。老兄。我知道。而且是一脸正经地说出来的。但他们设计冷藏箱并不是很管用。食物运到目的地时会腐烂或发霉，没有人明白为什么。集装箱行业遇到了冷藏箱问题，他们需要帮助。
My name is Barbara Pratt. Reefers meet your master. I'm the director of Refer Services for Mersecline today. That's Barbara Pratt and Mersecl is the biggest shipping company in the world. But back in the 1970s, Barbara was just a college kid. And so this professor at Cornell knocked on my door and said, Hey, Barbara, would you like to do some research? Barbara was about to graduate from Cornell with a degree in physics. She'd been planning to go to grad school.
我叫芭芭拉·普拉特。冷藏箱，迎接你们的主人吧。我是马士基航运公司今天冷藏箱服务的总监。那是芭芭拉·普拉特，马士基是世界上最大的航运公司。但在20世纪70年代，芭芭拉还只是个大学生。所以康奈尔大学的这位教授敲了敲我的门说，嘿，芭芭拉，你想做点研究吗？芭芭拉即将从康奈尔大学毕业，获得物理学学位。她原本计划去读研究生。
But she agreed to defer for a year or two to work alongside her professor and a team of researchers on a project for general foods. Their mission was to understand what was going wrong with all these shipments. Basically, the whole industry was blind to what was happening in transit. They would place 30 to 40,000 pounds worth of produce into a container, put it on a ship, and then see what happened at destination. It was like, now behind door number one, will the pizzas be rotten or underripe? If only 50% of the produce ended up in good shape, that's what would be consumed and the rest would be thrown in the trash. Barbara and her team decided the only way to see
但她同意推迟一两年，与她的教授和研究团队一起为通用食品公司的一个项目工作。他们的任务是弄清楚所有这些货运究竟出了什么问题。基本上，整个行业对运输过程中发生的事情一无所知。他们会将3万到4万磅的农产品放入集装箱，放在船上，然后看目的地发生什么。这就像，现在在1号门后面，披萨会腐烂还是未熟？如果最终只有50%的农产品状况良好，这就是会被消耗掉的部分，其余的则会被扔进垃圾桶。芭芭拉和她的团队决定，要了解
what was happening to the produce inside the containers was to follow the containers from farm to truck to train to ship. They'd need a lab, but it would have to be a mobile lab, one that can move with the shipments. And so of course, Barbara's research team would build their lab in a shipping container. It's really the only thing that made sense. Whether it was in the various terminals, in the fields, or even on board the ship, to then connect up to the other refrigerated containers that were moving on the ship to monitor what was going on inside the transit. And that's how at 22 years old, Barbara began traveling the world, working and sometimes sleeping in a 40-foot shipping container.
集装箱内部农产品发生了什么，唯一的办法就是追踪集装箱从农场到卡车、火车再到轮船的全过程。他们需要一个实验室，但它必须是一个移动实验室，一个能随货物移动的实验室。所以当然，芭芭拉的研究团队在一个航运集装箱里建造了他们的实验室。这真的是唯一说得通的做法。无论是在各个码头、田野里，还是在船上，然后连接到船上移动的其他冷藏集装箱，以监测运输过程中发生的情况。就这样，22岁的芭芭拉开始环游世界，在一个40英尺的航运箱里工作，有时甚至睡觉。
We converted this container to basically a laboratory, a self-sustained laboratory, so that we could repeat our science while we were in transit. They worked with the company in Southern New Jersey that made mobile homes to outfit their ship and container. You know, make it a little cozier. And we would have the front section which had some bunk beds in case we needed to stay overnight. There was a microwave, a shower, and of course a refrigerator. It actually looked pretty cool with black and white checkered floors in a window. A small, bulletproof window, you know, ports are not known for being super safe. But it was fairly pleasant. But at the heart of the mobile research lab was the computer.
我们将这个集装箱基本改造成了一个实验室，一个自给自足的实验室，以便我们在运输途中可以重复我们的科学研究。他们与新泽西州南部一家制造移动房屋的公司合作，来装备他们的船和集装箱。你知道的，让它更舒适一些。我们的前部有一些双层床，以防我们需要过夜。里面有一个微波炉、一个淋浴间，当然还有一个冰箱。它看起来确实很酷，有黑白相间的格子地板和一扇窗户。一扇防弹小窗户，你知道的，港口可不是以超级安全闻名的。但它相当舒适。不过，移动研究实验室的核心是计算机。
And what's really funny about it is we had a computer which was the latest and greatest at the time, but it was about two feet square by three feet square by about eight feet tall, and that basically gave us the computing capability that a laptop has today. Attached to the lab computer were 150 sensors connected to all the other adjacent containers by long, grey, salt-resistant wires. These wires were sending back all kinds of information
真正有趣的是，我们拥有一台当时最新、最好的计算机，但它大约有两英尺乘三英尺见方，大约八英尺高，这基本上赋予了我们今天笔记本电脑拥有的计算能力。连接到实验室计算机的是150个传感器，通过长长的、耐盐的灰色电线连接到所有其他相邻的集装箱。这些电线发回了各种信息
about what was happening in the containers. Temperature, humidity levels, air flow, concentrations of different atmospheric gases. Starting in 1978, Barbara, along with a small research crew, went with the mobile research lab to trail produce from its harvest on the farm to its arrival in their destination ports. We were in different countries in the Caribbean, we were in Asia, we were on the US West coast, US East coast, we were over in Europe. So remember, Barb was only going to do this for
关于集装箱内发生的事情。温度、湿度水平、气流、不同大气气体的浓度。从1978年开始，芭芭拉和一小群研究人员带着移动研究实验室，追踪农产品从农场收获到运达目的地港口的全过程。我们在加勒比海的不同国家，我们在亚洲，我们在美国西海岸，美国东海岸，我们在欧洲。所以记住，芭芭拉原本只打算做这个
like a year or two? What happened basically is I got hooked in the industry and I just stayed there. I hooked in the industry and I just stayed there. She kind of got hooked on reefers. For the next seven years, Barb traveled back and forth across the globe with the shipping container lab. She got the adventure she wanted, but she didn't have much time for sightseeing. We ran our tests and we were conducting our research
一年或两年？发生的情况基本上是我迷上了这个行业，然后就留在了那里。我迷上了这个行业，然后就留在了那里。她有点迷上了冷藏箱。在接下来的七年里，芭芭拉带着航运集装箱实验室在全球各地奔波。她得到了她想要的冒险，但她没有太多时间去观光。我们进行测试，进行研究
in analyzing data as we could during the days. When they were on land, out in the fields and orchards, they'd sleep in hotels. But one person would usually stay behind and sleep in the bunk beds in the lab to keep an eye on the computer. When they were aboard the boat, Barbara would pass the time doing some embroidery.
并在白天尽可能地分析数据。当他们在陆地上，在田野和果园里时，他们会住在酒店里。但通常会有一个人留下来睡在实验室的双层床里，以照看电脑。当他们在船上时，芭芭拉会通过做刺绣来打发时间。
Safe to say, Barb was the only one embroidering on the cargo ship. She was kind of a rarity, a young 20-something woman on the high seas. I found out about 15 years later that someone senior in the organization had told the people that were around me when I was working, that I had a black belt in karate so that they would know that I could defend myself. But you didn't have any actual martial arts skills. No, I did not at all.
可以说，芭芭拉是货船上唯一一个刺绣的人。她算是一个稀有人物，一个在公海上二十出头的年轻女性。大约15年後我才发现，组织中的某位高层曾在我工作时告诉周围的人，我拥有空手道黑带，这样他们就会知道我有能力保护自己。但你并没有任何实际的武术技能？没有，我完全没有。
But Barb had plenty of other skills. She and her colleagues were the first to map Airflow in a reefer. And the first to figure out how much produce could be stuffed in before air circulation started to suffer. With frozen oil, you really need to do is keep it cold. With produce, what you need to do, or with most of the produce, it's breathing and respiring product. And so what you need to do in order to preserve its shelf life is to slow down the breathing and respiration that's going on.
但芭芭拉有许多其他技能。她和她的同事是第一批绘制冷藏箱中气流图的人。也是第一批弄清楚在空气循环开始受损之前可以塞进多少农产品的人。对于冷冻货物，你真正需要做的是保持低温。对于农产品，你需要做的事情，或者对于大多数农产品来说，它们是呼吸和新陈代谢的产品。因此，为了保持其货架期，你需要做的是减缓正在进行的呼吸和新陈代谢。
Based on their findings, the standard ventilation system of a standard refore unit was completely redesigned. Air used to enter the container from the top. In the improved design, cooler air entered the container from the bottom. And then the air basically got forced up through the cargo, which then allowed it to remove the heat, which is what the whole focus of the air flow was. Their research also influenced the ways the growers would dry, prepare, and pack their products to be shipped. All to ensure that fruits and veggies could last two weeks on the ocean inside of a refrigerated tin can.
根据他们的发现，标准冷藏箱的标准通风系统被完全重新设计。过去，空气从顶部进入集装箱。在改进的设计中，较冷的空气从底部进入集装箱。然后空气基本上被强行向上穿过货物，这使得它能够带走热量，这正是气流的全部焦点所在。他们的研究还影响了种植者干燥、准备和包装要运送的产品的方式。所有这些都是为了确保水果和蔬菜能够在冷藏铁罐里的海洋上持续两周。
In short, the work that Barbara Pratt and her rotating cast of colleagues did during their seven years at sea, led to a world where Peruvian asparagus can reliably be found in American grocery stores. And New Zealand Kiwi Fruit are readily available on British supermarket shelves. So you still work in shipping, you've stayed in shipping ever since you got sucked in. What happens nowadays if you want to figure out what's going on inside of a reaper? You don't have to be on the boat, right? Not necessarily. Today the reaper units are all run by microprocessors, so we can see the digital recordings of those units
简而言之，芭芭拉·普拉特和她轮流更换的同事们在海上的七年里所做的工作，带来了一个秘鲁芦笋可以可靠地在美国家庭杂货店里找到的世界。新西兰猕猴桃在英国超市的货架上也随处可见。所以你还在航运业工作，自从你被吸引进去后，你就一直留在航运业。现在如果你想弄清楚冷藏箱里面发生了什么，会发生什么？你不需要在船上，对吧？不一定。今天，冷藏箱完全由微处理器运行，所以我们可以看到这些设备的数字记录
internally once they get to their destination. And these high-tech reapers are so reliable and so finally calibrated that they are now taking business away from air cargo, even for extremely fragile products such as fish and flowers. And they're basically affordable today whereas in the past they were not, is because they move via ocean. If they all had to move via air they would be very expensive for all of us. But we can bring in Italian grapes.
一旦它们到达目的地，就会在内部显示出来。这些高科技冷藏箱非常可靠，经过精细校准，以至于它们现在正在抢夺航空货运的业务，甚至针对鱼类和鲜花等极其易碎的产品。它们今天基本上是负担得起的，而过去不是，因为它们是通过海运运输的。如果它们都必须通过空运，对我们所有人来说将是非常昂贵的。但我们可以引进意大利葡萄。
We can bring in persimmons. We can bring in other products into this country that are not typically grown here. Even bananas are shipped in containers now. Chiquita, which is a descendant of United Fruit, recently sold off the last of its banana-only ships. And now Merisk is beginning to experiment with controlled ripening en route, inside the reaver, rather than in special facilities at distribution centers.
我们可以引进柿子。我们可以把通常这里不种植的其他产品引进这个国家。现在连香蕉都是用集装箱运送的。联合果品公司的后代奇基塔最近卖掉了其最后一批纯香蕉船。现在马士基开始尝试在途中在冷藏箱内部进行受控催熟，而不是在配送中心的特殊设施中进行。
All hail the reaver, the liverer, a perfectly ripe bananas! The global shipping industry, like it or not, is an undeniable part of modern existence, and of course, it's rife with its own problems. Yes, products are not as fresh after they've been at sea for two weeks, and all this refrigeration is really environmentally inefficient, and it's forcing small farmers to compete in the cut-throat global economy. Reefers seem to embody everything the local food movement is fighting, and you'd think that it would be Barb versus the local farmers.
向冷藏箱致敬，解放者，完美成熟的香蕉！全球航运业，无论你喜欢与否，都是现代生存不可否认的一部分，当然，它也充满了自身的问题。是的，产品在海上呆了两周后就不那么新鲜了，所有这些制冷在环境上真的很低效，它迫使小农户在残酷的全球经济中竞争。冷藏箱似乎体现了本地食品运动正在抗争的一切，你可能会认为这将是芭芭拉与本地农民的对抗。
I grew up and actually I'm still farming the same family farm, and we grow a variety of different products, mostly fruits and vegetables. Barbara is no stranger to the realities of running a small farm today, but she likes that small farmers can have an opportunity to access a global market. Barb is well aware of the value of eating local. But she defends the importance of just eating more fruits and vegetables.
我长大了，实际上我仍在经营同一个家族农场，我们种植各种不同的产品，主要是水果和蔬菜。芭芭拉对今天经营小型农场的现实并不陌生，但她喜欢小型农场能够有机会进入全球市场。芭芭拉非常清楚吃本地食物的价值。但她捍卫了仅仅多吃水果和蔬菜的重要性。
Yes, it's important to eat local, but in January and February, there are no local fruits and vegetables that we can eat. What has happened over the years is that people are eating more fruits and vegetables in general, because they have access to more products and higher quality products year round. It's thanks in part to Barb's research that we can eat blueberries or tomatoes whenever we feel like which bar bar Use will make us eat them more and it's all because of reefer That's never not gonna be funny to me I would just care to. What people read for the refus? Yeah, man. Meena Chessha,
是的，吃本地食物很重要，但在1月和2月，没有我们可以吃的本地水果和蔬菜。这些年来发生的事情是，人们总体上吃更多的水果和蔬菜，因为他们全年都可以获得更多的产品和更高质量的产品。这在一定程度上要归功于芭芭拉的研究，我们可以随时吃蓝莓或西红柿，无论芭芭拉怎么用都会让我们吃得更多，这一切都因为冷藏箱。这对我来说永远都不会觉得不好笑。我只是关心。人们对冷藏箱怎么看？是的，老兄。米娜·切莎，
Taylor, Taylor, Lightly. Oh, have you ever met that funny dream for me? This man! Have you ever met that funny dream for me? This man! If he says it walks the ocean and in time he takes notes and does talk to you, people may may. 99% Invisible West Produced This Week by Nikola Twilly and Avery Trouffleman, with Sam Green's
泰勒，泰勒，莱特利。哦，你见过那个对我很搞笑的梦吗？这个人！你见过那个对我很搞笑的梦吗？这个人！如果他说它走过海洋，并且及时做笔记并与你交谈，人们可能会。99%隐形本周由尼古拉·特威利和艾弗里·特鲁弗曼制作，还有山姆·格林的
fan Katie Mingle and me Roman Mars. Our new digital director is Kurt Colstapp. Nikola has her own excellent podcast about food and the history and science of food. It's called Gastropod. You can get it at www.gastropod.com. 99% of us will celebrate our five year anniversary this week. Which is really hard to believe. Thank you for listening and telling people about the show that's the only marketing we've
粉丝凯蒂·明格和我罗马·马尔斯。我们的新数字总监是库尔特·科尔斯塔普。尼古拉有她自己关于食物以及食物历史和科学的极好的播客。它叫Gastropod。你可以在www.gastropod.com上获取它。99%隐形本周将庆祝我们的五周年纪念日。这真的很难以置信。感谢您收听并向人们介绍这个节目，那是我们唯一的市场营销
ever had and supporting us so that we can remain independent and growing from year to year. Your dedication to this program has really meant the world to me. We are a project of 91.7 KALW, San Francisco, and produced of the offices of Oxide, an architecture in interiors firm, in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook, we're all on Twitter, Tumblr, Instagram, and Spotify, and you can download every episode of 99% of visible at 99pi.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一直以来都有，并且支持我们，以便我们能够保持独立并在逐年增长。你们对这个节目的奉献对我来说意义重大。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，并在美丽的奥克兰市中心的一家建筑与室内设计公司Oxide的办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞，我们也在Twitter、Tumblr、Instagram和Spotify上，你可以在99pi.org下载99%隐形的所有单集。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子以发表评论。